what we find is that women remove
themselves if you have a parent that
turns up with their daughter to play a
rugby game and they recognize that
there's a male on the opposite team the
parent will remove their child yeah
exactly I'm a sensible dad I do not want
my daughter having a neck broken I'm
taking her off the field and one of the
things I find the most heartbreaking is
that we've had a massive increase in
primary schools now just having Sports
days which are mixed sacks so and then
I've lost kind of the number of parents
have contacted me with their you know 11
year old daughter who's come back from
sports day and said not a single little
girl won a race today dude
sometimes pinch yourself yeah all the
time every day I wake up and go how are
we here how has this happened we turn
around and say that we have to pretend
somebody is a woman then what's next you
know are people going to say that
they're 10 years older or 10 years
younger there's got to be reality and
truth I worry terribly about Free Press
and and free speech and you know if we
lose Free Speech we lose democracy
foreign
Francis do you think Financial platforms
should be apolitical and not cancel
people just because they don't agree
with their politics I'll never forgive
what those absolute
tide Bank did to us now Francis we don't
know if our bank account was canceled
because of our politics give me five
minutes in a room with them and I'll
find out what are you gonna do test your
new jokes on them yes and More Celine
Dion impersonation
don't want to see that
uh moving swiftly on if you're looking
for a crowdfunding platform then you
have to use give send go gifts and go is
a crowdfunding platform that is
available in over 80 countries and
provides a simple and easy ways to raise
money online they are politically
neutral and don't remove campaigns based
on political or ideological differences
we all know that a lot of crowdfunding
platforms cancel people if they don't
agree with their Politics the more we
support companies providing alternative
models the more we weaken the power of
cancel culture what's more gifs and go
is a free platform powered by donations
which means that you get to keep more of
the money you raise other crowdfunding
sites charge between five and ten
percent ten percent of the total money
raised is a huge amount Gibson gold can
be used to raise funds for medical
expenses business ventures personal
needs churches non-profits funeral costs
and much more so let's take a stand
don't give your business to companies
that have made it clear they don't want
you choose hope choose Freedom choose
give send go go to
www.givesandgo.com and check out a
better alternative to crowdfunding
that's
www.givecentgo.com and support the
people who support freedom
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today is a
former professional swimmer who won a
silver medal competing for this country
Great Britain Sharon Davis welcome to
trigonometry thank you very much nice to
be here oh it's so good to have you I've
been meaning to have you on the show for
a while you've been saying your opinion
about interesting things so we wanted to
talk to you about that before we do
though uh who are you how are you where
you are what has been the journey
through life that brings you to be here
talking to us gosh it's a long journey
so I did my first Olympic Games when I
was 13. well which was um yeah nearly
nearly 50 odd years ago now
and my whole career really I suppose
it's been swimming in Olympic Games and
every four years I get to another one so
I've done
30 or 13 will be Paris
um so you know sort of four-year
increments obviously one myself medal in
Moscow that you mentioned but obviously
Commonwealth medals European medals
World medals all the different medals on
the way spent much of my youth being in
a swimming pool smelling of chlorine
very very clean child
and then I went to University in America
after I won my my silver because there
was nothing really in this country
there's no Lottery funding in those days
so it was either the Dole or the
universities in America but to maintain
my scholarship I needed to swim and I
just needed a break you know I needed
six months off from doing six hours a
day of training and to be an 18 year old
for a little while and that wasn't
really allowed and I did a TV program
called give us a clue which you won't
remember because you were too young but
um it was just a quick show got paid 40
quid and got branded a professional and
wasn't allowed to compete anymore so I
spent eight years away kind of working
in television and doing all sorts of
different things and then I was at the
Olympic Games in Seoul with Mary Peters
showing a flap and Mary said don't spend
the rest of your life saying what if so
at this stage I was like 28 29 and I
thought well if I don't do it now I'll
never be able to do it so I got back in
the water and made another Olympics and
won a few more Commonwealth medals and
then met Derek Redmond at the Olympic
Games in 92 when he pulled his hamstring
oh
that that video is done trillions of
views and I cannot watch it without
crying I know well it's very authentic
that's the thing you know it really is
how his dad ever got out of the crowd I
will never know because I've been
security as you'd imagine at Olympics
it's quite intense
um and I we just ended up sitting on a
beach that night and he was saying I was
running so well and then I pulled my
hamstring and I was going I'm swimming
so well and then I did my best rooms at
training camp and and then we got
together after that and we have two kids
um we're not together now but we're
still good friends
um and then I've got a little one as
well who's 16. so that's kind of my
sporting career the rest of it is kind
of working in television working for the
BBC poolside I get to take a microphone
in front of all the swim which is just
the best job in the world
um
yeah and just recently written my book
unfair play about the challenges to
women's sport which has always been
there you know because obviously I was
competing during the East German era so
I won an awful lot of silver and bronze
medals behind East Germans and for that
that was allowed to go on for 20 years
tell people more about that because the
younger audience may not be familiar
Francis and I joke about it because I'm
from Russia and this sort of Russian
Easter Eastern German cheating and all
of that is kind of in our DNA but tell
us more because people may not be
familiar with this what were the
challenges to competition for women like
you and others in the past yeah so
during the the 70s and the 80s the old
um East Germany
um basically we're putting an awful lot
of nasty steroids testosterone into the
young girls as a program really to you
know to win in sport uh they totally
dominated in the women's events
obviously because what they could do is
they could create a sort of a male
puberty by giving these young girls
these terrible drugs from about 11 and
with massive side effects many of them
have been really poorly some have even
died
um this was allowed to go on for a very
long time
um the girl that bit me was was from
East Germany I've met her since and
she's got liver problems and kidney
problems and fertility problems and all
sorts of things they had big court cases
when the war came down in 89.
um we're all very aware of it at the
time you knew it was happening oh yes I
mean because they would turn up you know
at a major competition we'd never seen
them before
um they would look and sound like men
they had deep voices and you know
Shadows on their chins bless them and
bad skin and and and and male physique
and they swam like males you know they
would do male equivalent times
um
then they disappear again and we'd see
another one and the next major
competition you know and they would have
no hardly any success in the men's races
and this massive success in the women's
races so at European level they won 92
percent of the women's medals throughout
that whole period of time and
practically none in the men's and the
ioc went well they're not doing anything
and it was really really frustrating I
mean really frustrating and I suppose
that's why I speak out now it's the
biggest reason I speak out now because I
had friends that
came forth behind three Germans and
their whole lives would have been
different if they've been Olympic
champions and you use that term really
frustrating but
it's more than that isn't it Sharon
surely you know you've dedicated your
life to this your childhood you every
day eight hours a day and all of a
sudden somebody cheats yeah it's more
than frustrating isn't it it's the
Injustice of it I suppose it was the
Injustice of it for all of us because
even at the time we knew that they
weren't doing it kind of I I I'm
reluctant to say not knowing because I
think they must have known something was
going on no their bodies were changes
their voices were changing you know
they're going to ask questions they're
not stupid however there was very little
they could do about it so they weren't
in a position where they could control
it because what we showed I did a
documentary
um a few years ago and we went to the
Stasi files and and we could see that
they were making about a nine percent
Improvement so you could take a very
average swimmer a female swimmer if you
make you know nine percent Improvement
you make them world record holders so
they had this total you know they had an
infinite number of young girls they
could just move into the system fill
them from these terrible drugs and have
them as world champion so they didn't
need to look after their best swimmers
because they had a train of just young
girls you know that they were removing
from their families and putting them
into training programs so it was
horrendous what was done and you know
there's there was always two victims
there was the victims that were cheated
like myself and my friends and there
were these young girls that were
incredibly badly let down you know by
the ioc and why didn't the ioc get
involved in why did they not because if
it was as clear as day and it was really
does sound like it why did they not do
something and they still don't I think
now wow so we've had all the evidence
we've got all the paperwork we had
Germans they had court cases where I
think 25 million euros were given out in
compensation we've had um you know
admissions of guilt I've got admissions
of guilt from the the young woman that
beat me on tape that ioc will still do
nothing
and you just kind of you just I I find
it Beggars belief when they're supposed
to be promoting Fair sport you know
Sharon talk to us about your friends and
obviously you don't have to go into you
know personal details if you don't want
to but I think one of the things that
often gets missed in this whole
conversation is what sort of impact in a
competitive environment where it's not a
percentage thing it's not like well you
know this person got promoted unfairly
and they get three percent more money
and you don't it's like you either won
or you didn't yeah and the gap between
those two is is as you say life-changing
yeah it's absolutely the commercial gap
between being an Olympic champion and
being forced and no one ever remembering
who you were is huge you know it's
absolutely huge it's totally
life-changing and so it's that ability
to have that opportunity which I was not
prepared to let happen all over again
the same end result in the fact that
male puberty is enabling someone to have
an advantage you know one was artificial
with these German system one is a
natural process now and I just thought I
can't let this happen again I can't sit
by and watch a whole another generation
of young girls miss out and it's worse
really because in lots of ways with the
transgender argument is
um you've got all of the pathways you've
got all of the Masters events you've got
it across every sport across every
country whereas in my day it was just
the elite level and it was just
predominantly in say swimming rowing and
track and field you know it wasn't going
to affect the British national
championships or the American European
you know college trials or any of those
things whereas now it's affecting all
young women across the whole world
they're not getting their opportunities
to their success and it might be an
Olympic medal which is huge or it might
just be the fact that you make it to the
National the nc2as and you get to put
this on your you know on your CV for the
rest of your life which opens the door
for you when you're going for a job
application they're losing those
opportunities and that's not fair and of
course in America just to flesh that
point out a little bit because of the
way the whole sporting and college
system linked you could you could get to
college that you might not be able to
afford
and get a really good education based on
your athletic performance and yet here
you are
competing with people who are male
bodied to put a very which is the truth
the truth is that they are male bodied
and that will never change their
biological sex will always be male no
matter how much testosterone they reduce
no matter how much plastic surgery they
might choose to have and again that
doesn't happen in sport they don't have
plastic surgery they don't have genitals
removed you know and in a lot of cases
they try to reduce testosterone for
incredibly short periods of time uh like
Leah Thomas you know with the nc2as Leah
was asked to reduce her testosterone
levels to 10 animals of testosterone per
Lisa well that's 10 times what I have
and that was only for one year
I mean so the the difference is just
ridiculous that person goes from being
460th in America not in the world in the
world they would be not in the top 2000
in America 200 to being number one and
beating three American silver medalists
in the space of a year
so I'm in a very mediocre male athlete
becomes a very elite female athlete and
all those Elite female athletes have
spent 10 years of their life making huge
sacrifices I just expected to step aside
and Sharon when was the first moment you
thought we've got a problem here
um it's been in the background for a
while
um up until 2015 the ISE allowed males
to identify females if they had got a
certificate and had had genital surgery
um in 2015 it changed and it's got
progressively worse I mean to the point
now where the ioc don't even suggest
that anyone reduces testosterone they
just say you're not supposed to suggest
that anyone that's biologically male has
an advantage well that is the most
ludicrous thing to say because we have
men and women's races so if there's no
Advantage why are we having men and
women's races why don't we just have 100
meters on the track you know we know why
because we have two Sexes and so
therefore to offer opportunity across
Society we have all these different
types of categories and that's not just
male female that's age categories that's
para classifications that's weight
categories in boxing it's all sorts of
different categories to offer
Fair opportunity across society and did
in 2015 did the ioc actually give an
explanation because we all know the ioc
is how can I put it a little bit murky
let's say because we don't want to be
sued by them they're a little bit mergy
with their practices allegedly
yeah we go down that room no not really
I mean I think their problem is they're
just they're just worried about being
sued they're more interested in the
politics and the funding I mean I don't
understand how an organization's sole
job is to offer you know Fair Sports
just decided that women's sport didn't
deserve to be fair anymore
do you
sometimes pinch yourself yeah all the
time every day I wake up and go how are
we here how has this happened
why has this happened he's allowed this
to happen you know it just does not make
sense and how is everybody so scared
when not a single piece of science
backs up the inclusion of anyone that's
gone through male puberty into women's
sport as being fair we've got 18 studies
in the world the last came out of Brazil
in September of last year one of the
biggest and that showed even after 14
years of reducing testosterone we still
had no parody between people that were
male or female there were still hardly
any loss of Advantage so you know
there's not a single piece of study
that's that supports that inclusion and
yet here we are it's funny you say that
because we just had the comedian Simon
Evans on the show who he in his latest
show he talked about uh having problems
with his testosterone levels and he had
to get testosterone replacement and when
he was at his bottom he he qualified to
compete in women's competitions and
you're just going this doesn't make any
sense it makes no sense and it's also a
bit like you know like boiling an egg so
once someone whose male's gone through
puberty you can't unboil that egg right
so reducing testosterone doesn't make
any difference and it might mean you
don't get any any bigger or any faster
but then it's all relative to how much
training you do anyway so if you or how
much injury you've got all sorts of
different variables you know that are
involved in someone's physical
performance and and whether they're you
know a scale of one to ten
um and yeah just suppressing
testosterone in no shape or form you
know makes it Fair competition so you
said where did this come from how did
this come about who let it happen do you
have any thoughts on that
um I have a lot of thoughts
I mean I try to concentrate on sport
because it's what I know I know 50 years
of you know being involved in Elite
Sport I know Inside Out Back to Front
I've spoken to a lot of scientists A lot
of extremely well-known very successful
scientists um and people that know what
they're talking about it's important to
know the background of all of that I try
very hard to just stick to this area
because it's you know what it's like
it's a Minefield out there okay and I
want people to to listen respectfully to
what I'm saying and that's the reason I
did the book because I wanted to put all
of the evidence all of the gotchas all
of the science into one place that
people that want to try and fight this
and fight for their daughters and their
sisters and you know for their friends
to have Facebook where they could have
it a bit like an encyclopedia when they
could go to and they could get all of
that information and also wanted to show
the correlation the East German era and
what happened and why that happened
because of artificial testosterone and
to show the similarities you know of
what will happen again if we turn around
and allow unfair sport and I've you know
I was in the lucky position I suppose
where I could afford to take a bit of a
hit and I have seriously taken a hit but
I felt that it was really worth it you
know I wouldn't be able to live with
myself if I didn't so Sharon and you've
mentioned about the science and we've
touched on it a little bit so let's do a
deep dive into it what is the difference
between someone like Aaliyah Thomas and
someone like a Riley Gaines
yeah good good knowledge I like yeah
um so Riley and and Leah tied for fifth
place and and that's where Riley's got
all this bravery from because she was
asked to literally not accept her Trophy
and was told that the trophy could go to
Leah and Riley would have to wait for
hers you know and and I think she and
I'm so proud of her for doing that
because it's really hard as a competing
athlete to come at this beginning of
your career when you can be blacklisted
so bad to go forward in your career I
mean the University was horrendous it
blackmailed all its athletes who were
being asked to train change next to a
six foot four biologically male with
full male genitalia and we're told that
they would be sent to a psychiatrist if
they complained that's what the
University of Pennsylvania said wow yeah
and that's like so that's the stuff they
used to do in the Soviet Union is like
if you don't agree with us you go to the
the psych Hospital yeah that's insane
it's seriously insane it's so depressing
that that was what came out of America
that you know it it really is and so
Riley's been very brave to come forward
and to speak
um
the difference at Olympic level in sport
is between about 10 and 30 so something
like middle distance running is is 10
percent
uh weightlifting is up there at 30 so
the more explosive an event is the more
the difference between male and female
biology something like high jump long
jump quite explosive about 20 22 a male
of equal weight
will hit 160 harder than female and
that's on to a female bone structure
Which is less dense
women have a bigger Q angle because of
the size of our hips that means that we
hand up with six times more knee
injuries and things like football
because we obviously have this angle but
it means that a male will have more
ability to put power through their legs
on things like sprinting on striding on
a bike in particular it's a big
Advantage so these are all things like
reducing testosterone makes no
difference to whatsoever
so it's um it's massive you know when
you think that
um the nine percent that these German
women meant that they were unbelievably
dominant to the point of 92 of all the
European medals
and not 10 is the lowest that we've got
you know presently between male and
female performance
um yeah I mean it's it's catastrophic it
means that half the length of the pool
and Olympic medals are one by hundredths
of a second
so and also as well there's a lung
capacity issue as well yeah lung
capacity hemoglobin levels hands feet
you know Leo Thomas six foot four huge
great hands huge great feet those are
your paddles so you know all of those
things yes there is the odd very tall
female but it's you know six foot four
in swimming for a man is fairly average
that's not average for a woman the women
is about six foot we're tall breed I
mean each sport let's be honest you've
only got to look at the Olympic Games
you know you don't get six foot four
gymnasts no you don't get you know four
foot six basketball players or
volleyball players so so to be the best
in the world your physiology has pretty
much got to be right to do that Sports
um so yeah swimmers are fairly tall but
we're not that tall you know women are
on the whole about fine I'm 5'10 so 5 10
5 11 6 for most Sprints or female
sprinters will be around that
um distant swimmers can be a little bit
shorter
um but the guys are often six four six
five six six
hey Francis do you want to learn another
language no mate we voted brexit for a
reason well if you are open-minded
unlike Francis and want to learn another
language then Babel is the app for you
why would anyone want to learn that
foreign filth what's next eating snails
and frogs what kind of person goes
looking for food in the local pond dead
puns for breakfast weird Babble makes
learning a language quick and easy
because it focuses on natural
conversation 15-minute lessons are
designed to be the most efficient and
effective way to learn a new language
lessons are created by over 150 language
experts meaning real people so not the
French so you learn how to have a real
world conversation things you'll
actually use not meaningless phrases
per se isn't even the word mate the
great thing about Babel is that the
lessons are interactive they aren't just
robots talking they're voiced by native
speakers using a modern conversation
based method so in no time you'll be
speaking confidently about real life
topics in another language with Babel
you can choose from 14 different
languages including Spanish French
Italian and German even though that's
not a real language plus Babel speech
recognition technology helps you to
improve your pronunciation and action in
next to no time you'll be speaking
German just like I speak English yeah
trying to sell the product mate there
are so many ways to learn with Babel in
addition to lessons you can access
podcasts Games videos or even join live
classes with a language teacher start
your new language learning Journey with
Babel today right now Babel is offering
our listeners six months free with a
purchase of a six month subscription
with promo code trigger go to babble.com
play and use promo code trigger for an
extra six months free that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com play promo code trigger
Babel language learning that works
and why is it that female female
athletes I mean there are some righty
games is a great example of this haven't
stood up and gone no to be brutally
honest this is this is taking the piss
um unfortunately not the mermaid to sign
contracts
so they have contracts with their
governing bodies which are their their
associations and that doesn't enable
them to say anything that the
association thinks would be derogative
it would cause uh problems for them
um we also have contracts with their
sponsors so again that would stipulate
the same sort of things
um it's made very plain to them that
that it's not recommended that they
speak out and so that's why it's really
important that we have these Anonymous
polls but it took seven years for any
governing body to ask a female athlete
how they felt about enabling males to be
in their races
and you alluded to the some of the
things you've lost for speaking about
this issue can you talk a little bit
about that and because I think it ties
into why you're in a much more
comfortable position you you can't have
your potential dream of an Olympic medal
taken away you've been there you've done
it yeah Etc but for these young women
there's that punishment so what's
happened with you first of all
um just a loss of work you know trans
activists are can be very vicious they
will literally find out where you're
working who you're working with and just
attack and attack and attack and ring
and ring and phone and send letters and
just do everything in their power to
make it very difficult for companies to
work with you because companies at the
end they just don't want the aggro in
most cases you know so if it's going to
be between me or three other famous
British female athletes they'll pick
somebody else because they just don't
want the aggro
um so and then I had Charities that they
did exactly the same to Charities that
I've worked with for 30 years
um yeah they just made my life hell I
mean the worst one is when they attacked
my family you know because at the end of
the day I suppose that's my biggest soft
spot is my kids I love them to pieces
and I would you know die for them like
all of us would but
um most of the time it's
it's it's vile misogyny
and I've
my mum sadly died about four years ago
and she left me the money which has kept
me going
and I look at I think to my my mom was
looking down on me now she would be very
proud of me I mean I remember having a
conversation with my mum when she bought
her first house of my dad and she wasn't
allowed to be on the mortgage
because only my dad could be on the
mortgage so my you know my mom's
generation and my grandmother's
generation were the ones that fought for
us to have the the equality that we have
today and I just think at the moment
we're going backwards with regards to
women's rights and the misogyny that
seems to be around in the world at the
moment is just extraordinary and every
day it gets worse well that's and that's
the thing because I I think you know
there are elements that sometimes people
throw that word around where it doesn't
really apply we sometimes exaggerate but
on this issue I have to observe that
women who speak up seem to get way way
way worse yes treatment than men do like
I know lots of men who've made the
points that you've made yeah as
stridently but you're very diplomatic
actually about it more stridently and
they don't have half the nonsense that
you get why do you think that is
because I think it's
it's mainly males that do the attacking
it's mainly males that sit at home on
their you know on their social media or
um Are Ringing companies up it's it's
this this misogyny it is there is no
other way and I'm like you I I hate
using words you know like racist or
misogynist or bully unless it really
applies because I think all we ever do
otherwise is dumb down these words but
at the moment these words are just used
to be everybody over the head to silence
everybody constantly
you know and and it's we're just living
in such strange times and and I worry
terribly about Free Press and and free
speech and you know if we lose Free
Speech we lose democracy because
democracy is based on free space it's
that ability to be able to tell to speak
out to have a platform and people to say
that's rubbish
but we need to be able to say it in the
first place and then let's delve into
this you say involve misogyny and I
think it's really important that people
actually understand what you mean by
that because there'll probably be people
at home going oh it's being
oversensitive blah blah blah so let's
what would we mean well sport is
particularly run by men as well so in a
lot of cases particularly misogynistic
sports like cycling and Cricket they're
two of the worst sports that I've
literally just turned around and Cricket
in this country's self ID so all you
have to do as a male to play on the
women's cricket team mascara I'm a woman
that's it
I mean I mean that's how crazy it is as
far as the ECB is concerned That's how
little regard they have for their women
cricketers I mean women Cricket has
never even played a test at Lords in
this country
so and then cycling again a very
misogynistic sport wasn't you know
cycling wasn't even in the Olympics for
women until the 1980s
um so the book you know I mean there's
some of the things I found the book
quite extraordinary because I'm doing so
much research and had to be so carefully
wrecked obviously and very legally read
and so on and so forth but you know in
the 1980s when I was competing there
wasn't a single female sitting on the um
the ioc Committees
you know so and again even today the
females always have sitting on the ioc
Committees are from the Middle East
who aren't even in most cases doing
women's sport because they're not
allowed to I mean you know it's just
it's crazy so unfortunately that's the
problem a lot of sports are run by men
who don't have the same value of women's
sports as women do if this was a problem
which was affecting males sport men's
sport it would be sorted out if you
remember the situation we had with the
costumes a few years ago you know they
brought these suits out and they were
making a vast difference and Michael
Phelps when I'm not racing anymore
unless you get rid of these suits it was
sorted out within a few months and again
with the shoes when they brought out the
carbon shoes you know again it was
sorted out very quickly we're not
superstoria said I want to race with the
guys with my blades they went no because
they might have got beaten so you know
it gets sorted the moment affects men's
sport but with women's sport let's just
we'll just let it go because it keeps
all this political people happy and
keeps all the PC Brigade happy and so
they've literally kicked women's sport
to the side and not given it the same
respect that they give Men Sport and at
the moment you know the thing that I
always say is that at presently we are
literally assigned to our female
athletes who are not worthy of fair
sport
and do you think it's misogyny but also
do you think partly it's money in that
they make a lot more from male Sports
mail male athletes tend to be on the
whole bigger starts they generate more
advertising income etc etc so when
Michael Phelps goes I ain't doing it I
mean I'm assuming they say not in
swimming because yeah Michael Phelps is
a big star but then says Katie Ledecky
now
so you know in swimming we have a sport
where men and women race together we
train together and we have the same
Olympic Games and we're on the same
program and the television cameras are
watching the women's race and then
they're watching the men's race exactly
the same as they do with track and field
so yes you have the big stars but things
like football rugby Cricket yeah Veil
you know very male dominated big airtime
big money massive money in football I
mean outrageous you know money and
football about 11
000 men earn a living from professional
sport in England Great Britain at the
moment 1 000 women
so we already have a much smaller piece
of the cake you know our cake is Tiny in
comparison with to what men get and now
we're being told we can't even have that
well right I mean the piece of the cake
thing is you know it's irrelevant to
what you're talking about which is fair
play right I mean the and I was never a
professional athlete obviously so I'm
telling you things you already know but
it's like the whole point of Spore is
that it's about fair play and you see
who's best on Merit that's the whole
point that's why people love it that's
why people watch it that's why people
party there's a purity to it that's the
beauty of sport isn't it okay that's the
whole part I mean to be honest with you
fair should be across life shouldn't it
you know sport often is just an analogy
for life you know and I and you know
when I was working and I still do work
and work has definitely got a bit better
over the last year but I used to do a
lot of motivational and corporate work
talking about how Sport and business
were very similar you know it's about
the hard work it's about the preparation
it's about your team support the people
behind you looking after your team you
know and setting targets and focus and
all these things that apply to life in
general and resilience you know we have
our kids are not very resilient and so
sport is really important not only for
health and fitness and fighting obesity
but also for resilience for mental
health and it's it's a real trick that's
being missed at the moment with regards
to you know trying to help our youth who
have these increasing mental health
issues constantly resilience is is
probably what I got out of sport racing
those East Germans for all those years
and here I am now you know being
resilient yeah absolutely and it teaches
kids a very important two very important
lessons one is to win with dignity yes
which you know and to lose the grace and
to lose with Grace absolutely and to
accept loss and you see a lot of people
who are my age even older and you'd see
them lose even win and you go there's
not a lot of dignity here yeah I mean I
think what sport teaches you as well is
it teaches you that you actually learn
from your failures
you know you mustn't be afraid of
failing because failing teaches us a
lesson so we then we go home okay why
did I feel how do I how do I make it
better what what preparation what hard
work do I need to do to get better
and I think again we kids love a lot of
our kids and the fact they're never
allowed to fail we're frightened if they
fail but actually we're not doing them
any favors by not allowing them to fail
you know the lovely Chinese proverb that
says fall over nine times get up you
know get up ten and and that's yeah
that's really important that ability to
get back up and go again
and what is the ioc's explanation for
why they're allowing this one they don't
there isn't one what is the you know the
trans activist what's their argument
what is the what what do they say their
argument is if a trans woman says
they're a woman they're a woman and so
therefore they should be able to compete
in the women's competition I know my
answer will be well let's read let's
rename the category Lane let's go natal
female and open and So my answer to the
whole problem is go we'll have a female
protective classification which is
biological female and we have an open
and inclusive category for everybody
however you would like to identify and
I'm not transphobic I have I have
friends that have you know
two two transgender daughters and I'm
I'm a great believer that people should
be able to express themselves however
they they want to with safety and
dignity 100 however there has to be
fairness for everybody across society
and you can't just trump it all by just
going well because I say I'm this I am
this you know and what worries me is
where does this stop if we turn around
and say that we have to
pretend somebody is a woman and I my
definition of one was adult human female
um then what's next you know are people
going to say that they're 10 years older
or 10 years younger or different you
know what what there's got to be reality
and truth but so the thing we need to do
is to respect people that are
transgender women and transgender men
you know that's that's what we need to
do in sport it's quite fascinating
because if we have a transgender man so
a biological female that wants to
compete I.E the nc2as which is the
college championships in America same
thing that Leo Thomas competed in that
transgender man still opted to race with
the women which providing they're not on
testosterone nobody has a problem with
so if women can say you identify however
you like and providing or not taking
illegal drugs come race with us and we
will respect you why can't that happen
in men's races just the same well this
is the point I've made I have a friend
who's a former semi-professional boxer
female and we were talking about this
and I was sort of saying like we have a
word for injecting substances into your
body that enhances your performance
there's a word for that and whatever
motivation you have for doing it is
irrelevant because it enhances your
performance right it seems like a pretty
basic concept that people would
understand do you feel that there is
progress being made on this issue we
have seen some changes around the edges
certain competitions certainly there has
been yeah definitely it's taken quite a
while you know and a lot of pushing
um a lot of pushing back by a lot of
very brave people so World Aquatics were
the first of the Olympic sports really
the big Olympic sports which I was very
proud of
um actually World rugby were the first
to say we're going to protect the female
athletes because safety was an option so
okay so we're talking about back to that
boxing thing you know hitting 160 harder
imagine running at each other on a rugby
pitch you know the damage to people's
necks the spinal cords and things like
that I mean seriously in contact Sports
it was a massive accident waiting to
happen and there are still lots of
contact spots are not protecting their
female athletes football being one
um men kicks 50 harder so you know it's
this they are going to be life-changing
injuries if something's not done so and
then track and field sir Burley this
year protected track and field as well
um British Triathlon have been in very
very strong British volleyball been very
strong we're hoping well cycling will be
the next to do it but they have got at
the moment 50 50 just in North America
alone trans identifying males in women's
sport that are winning prizes all over
the place British cycling ever ever now
said we're going to protect the female
category but things like Park Run Park
run are allowing people to identify
however they want and course records
women's course records are falling every
single weekend across the UK
so why why wouldn't pot run just
introduce extra boxes for people to take
I don't get it you know it's it's an
easy thing to do people go online to log
in and you know to join up and I want
more people doing that I think it's a
fabulous event
but why should women be losing their
records the people that are male why
can't we just have a box that says
transgender woman and transgender men
and you have a transgender woman's
record and a transgender men's record
and a woman's record and a man's record
and an undertones record and you know a
master's record or whatever but they're
not doing that they're just allowing
people to self ID and of course again
it's women that will lose out constantly
do you think and this is not a
particularly nice question but do you
think it might need something drastic
like a woman gets seriously injured and
then we have lawsuits involved for the
actual real change to be made and people
go enough
and that's what I'm trying to avoid to
be honest with you that's what speaking
out I've been trying to I've been trying
to stop there having to be a Leah Thomas
in every sport before every sport does
the obvious
males are stronger and faster and more
explosive than females not because we're
better because we're different you know
we're built to do different things I'm
built as a species with a large gamete
to carry a child and to feed a child
that's why I'm made for okay you have
small guy might your job is different
and so it's not because we're better or
worse you know it's so insulting when
trans activists say women should just
train harder
huh
because I mean I was training six hours
a day
for 10 years of my life I break my arms
broke both bones in both arms my dad's
wrapped them in plastic bags and I
trained with two broken arms
the following year I tore the ligaments
in my knee my dad tied my legs together
for three months and I trained with my
arms only you know I could not have done
more
than I did
it was impossible and most the time I
was training with the guys and I was
beating quite a few of the guys but I
didn't beat the Elite guys you know I
was miles away I was 11 away from the
elite guys no matter how hard I trained
and when you see these people transition
for instance like Aaliyah Thomas
I mean it's very difficult to see
because there's a certain cynicism that
Creeps in are you cynical or would you
just try and remove yourself from that
line of thinking and just stick to the
facts I try really hard to stick to the
facts you know what I might tell you in
private might be very different from
what I tell you on film but I try very
very hard to be very logical very
fact-based very honest
um
uh just very straightforward with it all
really you know very scientific because
I think that's the only way that that we
can win ultimately
um I don't want there to be alert Thomas
and ebbistro and I don't want a woman to
lose her life or be you know in a
wheelchair to prove that a male is
stronger should never be in a contact
sport I mean boxing is an interesting
one because boxing um boxing have said
we will not uh that the mailboxes said
we will not fight a female
so if somebody wants to be a transgender
man and wants to go in a fight with the
men the men said we will not do it
because we will kill somebody
yeah so they'd created extra leaks yeah
um so they recognize that there was you
know potential for that that um
you know manslaughter charged to come
into it eventually Sharon do you think
this is a blip do you think it's just
fairly stagnant institutions
that aren't didn't see it coming it
blind signed to them it came out of left
field and now one of them is going to
catch up and then another one and quite
quickly this moment will be over or do
you do you think this is going to be a
battle that you're gonna have to keep
fighting for some time
um I'd like to think if the three big
Olympic sports you know protect their
female classifications then then all of
the other sports will find it a little
bit easier to follow but there are a lot
of very misogynistic Sports at the
moment that are run by what I would call
the old school which are dragging their
feet and in North America it's
particularly difficult I mean we even
got Biden at the moment talking about
you know removing the protection of
Title IX now Title IX came in in 1972 to
protect female Sport and to give females
the same opportunities to get to
University scholarships you know and all
those sort of things to have basketball
teams and women's football teams and all
the rest of it and they had a massive it
had a 300 Improvement rate literally
within the space of a couple of years
and female or participation in sport so
if we remove that and and allow people
to self-identify into women it's going
to go backwards and what we find is that
women remove themselves so if you if you
have um I don't know let's just be
hypothetical if you have a parent that
turns up with their daughter to play a
rugby game and they recognize that
there's a male on the opposite team the
parent will remove their child
I do not want my daughter having a neck
broken I'm taking her off the field and
that's so we end up self-excluding
so less and less women are taking part
in things and doing things they're
self-excluding because because it's
unfair and one of the things I find the
most heartbreaking is that we've had a
massive increase in primary schools now
just having Sports days which are mixed
sacks
I've lost cat the number of parents have
contacted me with their you know 11 year
old daughter who's come back from sports
day and said not a single little girl
won a race today
because all the races were mixed
and what message are we giving little
girls
a they're not entitled to fairness a b
they can't win
I mean it's just crazy
and also there's no point in even trying
exactly that's that's the point so they
give up so
it's outrageous and how hard it is
hard is it to have two races
but they're petrified of being accused
by you know somebody of not being PC and
so they're just taking the lazy option
and I don't understand why these
teachers these sports clubs these ngbs
are not
supporting their female athletes well
you make the point beautifully I think I
really look forward I haven't had a
chance to read the book but I'm going to
I really look forward to that tell
everybody tell everybody what it what
it's called it's called unfair play it's
about the Battle for women's sport
throughout history obviously having the
East German era a lot of
horrendous truths which I worked really
up in my eyes and obviously that where
we are right now with the back with the
transgender inclusion perfect uh but we
I don't want to wrap up yet because I
think what you were talking about with
resilience is actually something really
really important we're working on a
couple of projects around showcasing
that but uh you're a professional
athlete you talk about I mean bro
wrapping broken arms and plastic bags
you know knee injuries just stitches you
know that that sounds crazy to a normal
person I have to tell it's not normal
yeah
so talk to us about mindset talk to us
about that like how do you have that
level of determination that you're
willing to endure that sort of thing in
order to get to where you want to get to
I think it's the same as looking at an
entrepreneur you know that maybe has
lost their million made their million
lost it again and gone again you know
it's that that's a determination to want
to be the best you can be and the
sacrifices that are evolved to do that
the support structure you need that my
dad was my coach you know my parents
gave up all their summer holidays all
their spare cash for me to better do my
sport
um didn't get to travel around the world
watching me because they couldn't afford
it came from a very normal background
dad was in the Navy got invalided out
because he lost the sight in his eye
um and my dad spoken and because my dad
spoke out about the East Germans he was
never picked as an international coach
even though he had the only female
individual medalist on the whole of the
1980 Olympics which was me and he wasn't
picked because he spoke out so so even
though we think that we understand you
know the East German thing and we go of
course they were cheating why was it
more done we knew at the time and
exactly the same happened to him has
kind of happened to me
and is there a difference in mentality
between the individual individualist
sports like swimming and people who play
a team sport or is it kind of the same
um good yeah I think it's slightly
different because my son plays rugby
I've got a 16 year old as part of birth
Academy and my eldest played rugby at
milfield and my daughter did track and
field so they've all done sport
within the jeans yeah
um millfield's a very good sports school
for people who yeah
we used to play against them and get
slaughtered every time yeah he was on a
little bit of a scholarship but it was
still a very expensive school
um yeah I mean I think the mentality of
a team sport is that there's 15 of you
in rugby or 11 or whatever and so you
know you're part of a like a cog in a
machine and all of it has got to work
together and everyone's got their job
whereas in an individual sport it's just
you and I must admit I always felt that
I was an individual I didn't like being
in a team I didn't like feeling like I
had to rely on somebody else being on
their a game it was down to me and if I
wasn't on my a game it's my fault so so
yeah I think there is a you know certain
mentality to people that want to do it
individually versus people that want to
do it in the team but there's still huge
sacrifices and hard work involved yeah
the physical you know the fact that you
weren't happy to beat your body up to
the nth degree I mean you know Summers
our injuries are shoulders because we're
rotating all the time but you know you
look at I was talking to to Lee Dixon
earlier this week because he's got a
knee issue and I've had some knee issues
and he was talking to me about all the
Ops he's had you know from football ACLS
all the time whatever uh Steve Buckley
had a hip replacement at 39 because he
was constantly twisting you know to
throw a javelin so we rack our bodies
bodies aren't designed to do six hours a
day you know repetition no they're
absolutely not
another thing that I wanted to ask is
that a lot of athletes talk about this
mindset that when they cross a
metaphorical white line when they go and
play football it's a rugby or swimming
as well that they kind of change as
people did you have to you know you
become more ruthless you become more
direct you leave you know the Sharon
Davis who's the daughter the friend the
mother that's
back in the changing room when you're at
when you're out there you want to
destroy
um
so is a champion made or born a question
yeah yeah so a bit of both because
because ultimately there's got to be
something in you that makes you want to
win regardless and that I think is
genetic that is just Who You Are
and then the other bit is is all the
ingredients in the cake there you know
do you happen to be the right size to do
the sport that you want to do
um do you have the right support
structure do you have the coaching do
you have the access to the pool does
your body not break down and enable you
to do the training that's required you
know those are all the things that have
to go into making this cake that's got
to be presented on the day and
absolutely beautifully and so you got
and you win the Olympics or whatever so
it's definitely a bit of both I mean if
you said to me you know if I was playing
game of cards did I care whether I win
or lose I'll tell you I want to win you
know that's the way that I made just the
same
um Michael Jordan is famously like that
like he cannot lose anything you know
it's in your DNA isn't it that you
that's what's important to you you know
you want to win I think having a family
as a woman definitely makes you a little
bit softer you know it it you you change
your priorities a little bit
I mean I've my wife has had a baby they
just it was a big change with my man dad
isn't it but I think mum's in particular
all of a sudden they just go down that
pecking order until they realize that at
the bottom of the pecking order
everybody including the dogs
uh talk to us about losing uh it sounds
like a loaded question but it's not
everybody loses in life everybody
experiences setback and sport in many
ways is we talked about a little bit
earlier is the perfect place to know and
learn how to lose well how to bounce
back what what is your advice what are
your thoughts on people experiencing
difficulties and setbacks in life how do
you bounce back from a setback
I think it's the understanding of you
get something positive out of everything
you do you know whether it's an
experience or just learning it's not
what you want to do you know you think
about lots of youngsters nowadays you
know trying to pick their options or
pick what they want to go to university
or what their first job is going to be
you know and I've always said to my lot
just you go and do it go into if it
doesn't work you can change your mind
you can change mine go start again do
something totally different but be brave
enough to go and do it so I think sport
for me taught me to be brave it taught
me to just try things and if it doesn't
work well I learned that I didn't want
to do it that's a good lesson
um and instead of being afraid to not
try
and what was it like to represent your
country I imagine that must have been
such a thrill I was doing it at such a
young age it sounds silly but I kind of
just grew up with it all you know I was
uh
um a question I often get asked or it
must have been incredibly daunting being
at the Olympics at 13. actually it's the
opposite because when you're yeah so
when you're there as a youngster you're
like wow this is cool and you know oh my
God the world's watched me it doesn't
occur to you what is in your back of
your mind as well I'll be here in four
years time and I'll be really good
whereas so I went up to my first limits
I'm like oh this is fabulous I'm getting
to find out where the change rooms are
how this works what an Olympic Village
is like what the food Hall's like I
never thought oh my God I'm like a
rabbit in headlights I was just soaking
it all up thinking I've got my future in
front of me which is really positive it
gets really scary when you spent 10
years training and you've got one race
coming and you know there's not another
one you know that there's that one race
on that one day and if you mess that up
there will never be another chance ever
that's quite scary and that's the
difference between an leads athlete and
someone who's got you know
loads of talent is that ability to
handle pressure yeah I think so I think
the mental strengths to be able to put
it into context you know and to
understand there is an Olympics it is
really special however it's not life and
death you know something it was to go
drastically wrong you will survive you
will still be there the next day
Sharon Davis has been an absolute
pleasure speaking with you uh we're
gonna go to locals for our supporters
questions that they've already submitted
for you but before we do we always end
with the same question uh with all our
guests which is what's the one thing
we're not talking about as a society
that you think we're really should be
um
Dodge anything is a real
at the moment I would love to see more
men recognizing it and more men standing
up for women particularly in sport a lot
of the time they've sat on the fence and
stayed very quiet so I'd like to see
that happen a bit more
Sharon it's been a pleasure if people
want to buy your book if people want to
find you online where's the best place
we're everywhere we're actually in High
Street shops as well which is really
lovely uh we're on Amazon yeah so you
can find us pretty much anywhere
fantastic well thank you for being here
for the interview follow us over to
locals where we're going to ask Sharon
your questions
does Sharon think we should go back and
strip the records slash medals from past
steroid users slash abusers or should we
just draw a line and move forward from
here
[Music]
thank you